[Music]
everyone does love to dance to a happy
song I know I do
I know fund it does and hopefully our
next guest who's been kind enough to
come on the show
Imam unjam Chaudhary thank you for being
on the show sir no we're glad to have
you so you were you were very quick
actually in your response to do the show
which I was I was kind of surprised
considering I'm sure you know that I've
been critical of Islam in the past what
was your reasoning to just want to come
on and discuss right away are you just
open to do it doing every program you
can and getting the word out I should be
you know I haven't heard of your show
before I was contacted that may come as
a surprise to you but in general I
believe that if there's no summarization
yeah I believe so debate in this closet
discussion we can reach the truth I mean
you know there are many people we didn't
agree with the process of God you know
over the generations and yet they change
their mind okay so do you consider
yourself a prophet of God I'm a follow
on the prophets but there are best
examples okay so let me ask you this I
want to be fair
Imam unjam what do you prefer I'm good
enough
I'm Jim okay great so of the over you
know 1 billion Muslims in the world how
representative do you think your view of
Islam is to be would you consider it in
line relatively with the mainstream
thought in in Arab in Arab Muslim
countries when the problem that we face
is that in the kind of one and a half
billion Muslims that we have nowadays
they are divided into about 55 nations
and none of those nations implement the
whole of the Sharia now what in terms is
that there is no education system in
Islam nowadays in Muslim countries and
therefore the vast majority of the
people are very secular and they don't
really practice I suppose is similar to
Christianity right essentially say I'm
sorry what essentially says don't judge
me according to what the people say
the statements according to the Kieran
revelation because that is surely the
opposite sure so you would say I don't
want to misrepresent you for example I
would say that there are a lot of people
out there who claim to be Christian but
they're out doing drugs partying they're
checking the Christian default box you
would say that of many Muslims who don't
really believe the teachings that you
follow you would say they're secular
Muslims more or less absolutely I mean
this is a problem that is very easy to
let me ask you this since use it up who
carries out Sharia in the world most
closely to your beliefs what resembles
your view ideally most closely right now
which country well I don't think any of
them differently but I believe that what
is the project in Syria and Iraq and
places in Mali Somalia Afghanistan etc
are doing quite well but of course you
know human beings make mistakes and the
best among them of those are so given us
some change so Syria Iraq so Isis you
think is doing a bang-up job
well I think that Isis don't exist
anymore in fact I mean to be fair they
dissolved in June 2014 what you have
today is a collection of different
organizations and individuals and
scholars who make up the administration
and suddenly you know there's made
mistakes but I think that internally
they're making the Sharia they're
providing the basic needs for the people
there yeah many would consider genocide
a mistake let me get to the Paris
attacks here you I don't want to
misrepresent you didn't quite defend the
Paris attacks or maybe did you you
justified them why actually no I didn't
just justify them what I did I explained
the mindset of people who would carry
this out because can you condemn them
then what give you a chance to well what
I mean if you just explain one thing
that insulting the honor of any prophet
of God whether that be Jesus or Moses
and even Muhammad sallallaahu I'm
carrying capital punishment in Islam and
what I was basically saying that this is
the job of the state
let me ask up an actually do you see a
problem with that because let me tell
you that I mean do you notice there's no
other religion in the world you can make
fun of Jesus all you want I don't care
go live your life fun dip my producer
here is an agnostic atheist the only
religion in the world is is your version
of Islam which you claim to be the true
version that would bring death to
someone simply for not accepting the
Prophet what kind of a God would would
dress people that way not give them that
choice and it's face you know face this
religion accept it or death well I would
make your point
first of all that there are values which
you will fight for an even title I mean
obviously there is capital punishment in
America you have the gas chamber exactly
so there are picture not for not for
drawing about your coming one I'm coming
on to that but what I would say to you
is obviously there are different values
which people who consider a matter of
life and death and for us the sanctity
of any prophet of God and the Quran is
that and what I would say to you is that
if you don't accept accept the
inevitability of the Quran and a
Messenger Muhammad obviously you're not
going to understand that the Muslim we
do understand that well just like
obviously you know you don't understand
freedom I guess you don't believe in
guys I mean I do understand okay so the
message because I was born I was born in
Britain I just spent 48 years old I'm a
lawyer by profession actually and I
teach comparative law English and Sharia
law even freedom pretty well do you
believe in freedom of speech do you
believe so much to be able to drive I
believe that I believe is no such thing
as freedom of speech what we have is the
Allah created for us not fair for you to
say that say I'm a lawyer but you're a
lawyer who doesn't believe in the
freedom of speech so we have a
fundamental difference let me ask you
this how weak is your God that he can't
handle an insult from someone like me
what why would your God be offended by
someone as minuscule as me drawing a
picture of Muhammad you can see why the
people who aren't Muslim they go well
that's that's a pretty weak God
well let me just come on to that in just
one moment I was just about to say that
obviously your speech is Cottrell's
nowadays Cataldo give angle or is
curtailed by my middle
you obviously have in sideburn and
hatred laws and Sedition laws and
anti-semitism laws so we both agree that
you can speak but there are restrictions
now and agree I don't believe in hate
speech laws I don't believe in a trance
period yes but I mean you agree that
there should be some restriction to
people speaking you know example I'm
sure you would say that you can't shout
fire in a crowded theater well maybe the
kind of thing that you do where you
called it for the death we agree that
there should be some restrictions on
speech threat that's not free speech see
well we'll fundamentally disagree on
that there's no way we can come to terms
because I don't even believe in hate
speech laws you're talking to someone
who very least and by the way I
appreciate this about you you're honest
and you're consistent I have to be
honest and I have to be consistent
there's one thing I would like to talk
about since we have an outright
condemned the Paris attacks let me do
this let me close that topic on this
I've been very outspoken against
Mohammed I have talked about why but
listen I'm a Christian I believe him to
be a false prophet personally and I have
spoken about him in a way that many
Muslims would consider mocking or
dishonouring do I deserve to die well
actually I don't mean there's any
problem with someone disagreeing and I
need the questions and the time of the
Prophet but there's a difference if you
disavow me to finish there's a
difference between disagreeing something
not believing that he's the prophet of
God
I'm deliberately insulting him or making
caricatures which are you know done that
deserve to be killed I've done all those
things do I deserve to be killed what I
don't know about your history and I
don't know about what you've done I've
only heard about your show when I was
invited on rest up as Mohammed and
performed a Three Stooges routine with
my two young wives one of whom was
actually 9 to mimic Aisha do I deserve
to die well you know you would need to
be a counted initially a court the
evidence they need to be presented I
can't pass the verdict
on your show but definitely knowing the
honor in general any pictures okay so do
a capital punishment drawing any
pictures of Mohammed capital punishment
there we go that was the answer sorry
not necessarily because severe being is
there's a difference between drawing
something and assuming by the individual
that he's doing something worthy or
something respectable understanding that
you cannot draw I don't see what this
Charlie Hunter did I don't if he's
learning the drugs but extremely nasty
and hateful having that anyone would be
offended if you almost even on Muslim I
would agree with you that they were
nasty I wouldn't agree that everyone
would be offended someone I mean they
did that you know what we call the the
the P Christ was a famous piece of art
and you know what Christians did yeah we
kind of don't like this and they they
they turned away from it can I just make
one one one small point that you know I
mean there is often this argument that
you know because they're doing it to
everyone it's justifiable and I don't
think that is the case I mean if
someone's committed in crime with one
person it doesn't mean that because he's
doing it with everyone
it becomes justifiable I think that we
need to control our tongue we need to
have respect for each other and
ultimately having the good world would
be a much more assertive race it's not
what the case Oh see what see there is
that that veiled threat at the end the
world would be a much safer place I
think we should be honest of each other
civil sure but I don't think that should
have any effect on safety whether
someone makes fun of a prophet or not
that's where I disagree yeah but if you
know that other people have the sanctity
of the Prophet as a matter of life and
death in their own beliefs then
obviously that is something that we must
take into consideration now you made
this or that but that is the situation
with Muslims no I agree the the
situation as you've spoken before is
convert convert or die and you can
become you can become you become look I
mean you know you may know in the heart
of Europe for 800 years the Jews Muslims
and Christians and I'm side-by-side it
was never the case of forcing the
Christians would used to become Muslim
they were happy and in fact it was the
Christian harmony on the Queen Isabella
and King Ferdinand that led the Jews to
run to the Islamic state an advocate for
protection
yeah actually it's funny enough in the
Middle East there's one place where
Muslims live freely and open to pray
just religion as they choose and that's
Israel and that's a big irony of our
time being bulldoze down and you being
tough on your home there are millions of
refugees because of the Hashem in Iran
the occupying use let me ask you this
you talk about them living in peace
so okay let's take that premise you if
you talk about living in peace me as a
Christian living under Sharia right I
wouldn't have to pay any kind of a tax
or anything like that right we would
have the exact same rights as citizens
we would be traded zero differently just
like in America right actually you know
the difference is that Islam crease York
or at least so you would not have to pay
the times you would on to pray five
times you love to make a pilgrimage to
Makkah and you know many of the things
we shine comfortable Muslims will not be
incumbent upon all Muslims you will
never be asked to join the army to
protect the citizens but would have to
pay you have to pay the jizya decision
so that means much less than the Muslims
paint under the card you would be able
to practice your religion in your church
in your homes and you know nobody's
going to be spying on you and I came in
here in your own private places but
definitely the law of the man in the
public arena would be sharing it right
and that law of the land would result in
the killing of a lot of Christians or
Jews who weren't willing to because if
you look if you look if you look at the
statements of the Prophet even on his
death that he said whoever harmed in me
are ye a non Muslim citizen he said he
harms me and I would be a plaintiff
against him other than judgment he said
whoever kills one you know without any
any justification he will never smell
the paradise so you know these are
protected people under the Sharia now
what people may do is not a recession as
the salary of what the divine law says
okay I have two questions for you
because I want to give you the chance to
speak but I know you're also rushed for
time to prepare for your Friday prayers
and I want to be respectful of that
what about Isis and the crucifixion of
Christians where does that fall
there's no cool twist addition the
crucifixion of Christians but what we do
have if you look in the Quran in chapter
5 verse 33 what I said in the Quran I'm
around paraphrasing is that those people
who violate the public thanks to you in
other words for example going around in
gangs raping pillaging etc they have
capital punishment I know Simon couldn't
crucifixion or I could be cutting their
hand and leg from obviously directions
this
well it says in the Quran you can read
that for yourself okay that's fair
now listen I want to I also want to
actually defend something that you said
you were on a talk show and someone
asked you about you know suicide bombing
which you said is not a term you really
use but using your body for Allah is the
way that you view it which I understand
according to your beliefs is fair and
they ask you about the 72 virgins and
you made the point that 72 is often
misquoted right it's it's taken out of
context it really can mean countless
virgins and to not limit your mind to 72
that Allah could provide as many virgins
as one wanted right actually I believe
that forget about the versions Allah can
provide you eternal bliss in any shape
form or way that he pleases
I mean hereafter as very different to
this life the women of paradise and all
the same as the women in this life so I
don't think we can meet that similitude
well okay people obviously you were
discussing the context of virgins and
your words were a countless virgins know
that those were your what I meant what I
meant to say that yes there are
narrations which talk about partners in
heaven but ultimately what I say as a
Muslim we believe that God can shower
you with ultimate blessings and things
in the hereafter with virgins think well
everything is include whatever whatever
you want in paradise you can have you
know this is visitor beauty of our being
online in this life sure well let me ask
you this though culturally what is it
that's so attractive about deflowering
innocent young virgins well there's
nothing at all that's why I say to you
is important to you not to make this
magnitude or the analogy with this life
because the wine well if you just allow
me to finish the wine of paradise is not
the same as the one in this life even
the lie and the people the partners are
not the same you would not be the same
so you know I don't think that this is a
really valid comparison even if the
Union the probably said what do you
think about it's different than
Hereafter
so know that you so you would say that's
just completely been taken out of
context nope no virgins at all so
there's no I'd concept of virgins for
people there is a mention in the
narrations of the process when will be
granted many many many partners you know
in the hereafter what I'm saying is
don't make the comparison with this life
and there many other verses and hadith
indeed notions of the Prophet which for
many other things in
what about those women do they ever say
in it or do they just show up crap well
I don't think as I said you're talking
about paradise you cannot make their
comparison you know and I could quote
you from your own Bible and talk about
things in paradise but also maybe we
don't make the comparison because you
know this is little bit those quotes
where is in the Bible of the promised
virgin I don't have the body I don't
have the body in front of me but I only
see how premises are many things and if
you're after in the Torah and the engine
and we can go into the heart of the
tidal fish okay I understand what you're
coming from but nowhere in the Bible is
a promise virgins that's the big
difference between Islam and the Bible
and that's why I would like you to point
me toward those but I do understand the
point that it's difficult to compare our
physical world as three dimensional
beings to the hereafter I think that's a
valid point before we go I've heard you
speak about this what about under Sharia
law beatings
what about hitting one's wife what about
the lashings against Christians again
you've kind of wiggled around where you
said Iraq and Syria are doing a good job
so obviously we see that kind of thing
there where do you line up on that damn
any kind of striking women at all in any
kind of beating of Christians as
unnecessary and uncivil yes I mean
there's nothing called beating
Christians there's nothing even called
beating your wife you know and the
Prophet is the best example he's never
laid a finger I mean on any of his ones
having said that he never beat any of
his runs at all no but having said that
you know the Quran in something this I
was chapter 4 the Quran talks about the
situation well if your wife is
disobeying you continuously not
fulfilling rights then it says first of
all separate the bad so that could be
obviously a Walmart it could be a week
or even onto a year unless that it has
been advised and even that could be up
to a year it could be a long time and
then after that it says a discipline
that the probably said whoever you
disciplined
he said avoid the face the Prophet early
do not even say nothing there'll be
nothing more than pushing or something
like that but you know a second because
I do listen I do want to let you finish
but you know you have a problem with
that I don't care whether you hit the
face or not I've read the Quran hadith
and am I mistaken where it says he
struck her causing her great pain let's
that's pushing Aisha let's just say it's
no no no he never he never laid a finger
on any of his ones I'm Winston and the
pinions you see our honor he's the best
example but he never laid a finger on
any of his wines and and you know he's
the best example in the Quran so you
don't use the hadith because it does
talk about mean there's nothing we
mentioned in the parameter already I'll
be teaching Sharia for 20 years yes
undulation like this well we've got the
quote right up here on screen the screen
and verse and the viewers can make their
decision but for me it's only 20 of
those teams of our enemies of the laws
of the Prophet lot this year who will
cause something like this but it's not
authentic it's not authentic so you have
to throw out that entire part of the
hadees hadees many of them have been
fabricated and there's nothing like that
at all
okay I'll send you can narrate it okay
so it is there but it's just something
that you wouldn't use and that's fair
I mean we could make up a lot of things
but the point is I'm saying to you is
not a stream well I mean you know if you
want to find something you would always
find some people who are enemies of the
rise of the product like this year who
would say things like this we're about
Quran 434 yes this talks about what I
was talking about earlier about if
you're wanting to beat him then first
afraid the best what I'm trying to get
at is when throm tries everything to
avoid any confrontation you know in this
country two women are killed by their
husbands every week because of domestic
violence they sometimes everything to
avoid that meaning Faisal was separated
imagine kudo could cool down after one
night and after that advise that could
be a long time yeah they're not alike
even if there's discipline then avoid as
much as you can don't leave any marks so
you know this is avoiding domestic
violence at all at all costs you know
the man is stronger than the woman we
all know that so we need to avoid in
doing something in anger and if some
deals with that kind of national
disposition in a way we should agrees
with our nature okay listen I can
respect that that is your view and I
hope that you feel I've let you speak
more than I think some of my
conservative
brethren talk-show host because I imaged
in what you have to say and you know
what listen I think it's enlightening I
believe everyone should have a voice at
the table and Imam and Jim we we hope to
have you back I would sincerely love to
have you back and continue these
discussions well thank you for being
very respectful and I look forward to
coming back on yourself thank you very
much
and we hope to see you soon and listen I
will tell you this just like you hope my
government to Islam I hope to see you
come to the cross one day but that's
because I love all my human brethren in
respect that well but I don't we lost
him we lost him but fun dip that was
quite the conversation